Speaker 1: Let's look at some stunning clips
you may have heard, or you may not that the
U.S. trucker convoy advocating for freedom
from.
Something mandates, I guess, that mostly don't
exist or I don't know, the U.S. trucker convoy
is demanding their freedom.
They have been oppressed by tyranny in different
things.
They've started to get close to Washington,
D.C., and some interviews have now been done
with them.
And it seems like a skit.
Here are the good liars, the good liars.
Who do they do this really, really well, interviewing
one trucker yesterday, and she is most concerned
that they want to digitize.
Excuse me.
I can't.
I can't even say the word digitale us like,
you know how you would tile a shower and digitize
so it's digitale.
She doesn't want to be digitized.
Wow.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: Are you really concerned about
right now?
I don't want them to digitalis.
You don't want to.
What Digitalis?
I don't want to take medicine that will hurt
people.
What was the what was the word you use, though?
I haven't heard that digital?
Digital digital.
And what does that mean?
They're trying to they're trying to make us
robots, they're trying to make it where we
have no choice and nothing to where
Speaker 1: they can maybe buy digital.
She means like made into an android or something,
Speaker 3: or they can control us from what
they putting in our bodies.
And eventually, we'll actually be robots.
According to what they're saying, not robots,
but according to what they've already got
a man made working female robot.
Speaker 1: Maybe, I guess she's talking about.
Like those sex robots that recently made news,
I don't even know, but how how wild is that
guys like how much of this entire trucker
convoy fiasco is just the result of bad education
and confused people?
I mean, this woman seems to not have any idea
why she's there.
She's there because they want to digitize
us.
I mean, it's is.
Is it that, you know, we talk about, well,
you know, there's sort of like these misunderstandings
about what liberty and freedom are and people
want freedoms absent responsibilities and.
And it's like, are we just doing too much?
And it's just like they want to digitize us.
It's just confusion and bad education.
Is it just that simple?
Here's another interview with some.
Truckers, I guess, is what we're calling them.
And these folks want, they believe the Russian
invasion might be fake.
It's just it's not really going on, I guess
Speaker 3: easily fake a war if they wanted
to.
All they would do is just like film a few
things.
And are you aware that the majority of the
pictures that they've been showing regarding
the alleged war in Ukraine are from prior
conflicts and are unrelated to Ukraine?
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
We shouldn't have anything to do with it at
all.
Let them figure out their on us,
Speaker 1: the very patriotic honking in the
background.
As you can hear,
Speaker 4: state has always made Putin to
look like the bad guy, but he's a good guy.
Free.
Speaker 1: OK, so the war is fake also, that's
another, you know, pretty big brain take.
And then here's one more clip of a guy wearing,
I guess, some kind of head.
It's almost like a chain link armor.
I'm sure these things have specific names,
but I don't know them.
Take a listen to this guy.
Speaker 4: Is this a crusade to the government?
Believe it's a people's crusade because it
doesn't, you know, can be peaceful.
But you know, it's a crusade in the fact that
all people have to fight the evil in the world,
man and the evil they know about is.
Well, you're heading down to the evil in the
world and people have to band together and
fight on the side of the Lord.
You know, God wills it, man, fox, one who
is
Speaker 1: in the ranks here.
So anyways, so that guy thinks that they're
basically doing, I guess the I guess God wants
there to be a convoy and they are.
They're doing their thing.
Now, one other thing just this might be of
interest.
They I actually this is actually sort of smart,
like they're realizing that if they go into
D.C., they they might actually get arrested
at blocking traffic.
Different things.
So one of their, I guess leaders is framing
it as they're trying to sort of like goad
us into going to DC to then arrest us or something.
Take a listen.
Speaker 4: I hope Bryan browsing and the organizers
are fearful of them trying to tell us what
they did to those involved the January six.
And it is our belief that they will try to
do that.
So with that said, where are they in what
matters most?
Well, that means that we're not.
That's what that means at this time meeting
today and tomorrow.
We are not and will not go into D.C. proper.
Speaker 1: So that was disappointing to some
of the convoy people.
But others realize, you know, they're trying
to set us up like they set up the rioters
and we're not going into D.C.
Basically, the entire thing has fallen flat,
and the interviews with the vast majority
of the folks are indistinguishable from what
would be a Saturday Night Live skit.
One Saturday Night Live was at its funniest.
OK.
This year,